welcome to the stream so much to talk
about were actually tomorrow the entire
broadcast show is going to be an
in-depth interview with Dave Rubin host
of the Rubin report much anticipated we
received something like I want to say
about 350 or so questions across all
platforms for me to talk to Dave Rubin
about tomorrow we will have him for the
entire hour of the broadcast show and
then we will release that interview
starting tomorrow afternoon okay so we
confirmed with Dave earlier today and
that's gonna be a major major thing
tomorrow a lot of people want to know is
Dave Rubin conservative now what is Dave
Reubens view on XYZ why did Dave Rubin
say ABC and it's going to be a format
where I'm going to be able to ask him
those questions so thanks to again 350
people submitting questions and my
prediction is this will be a compelling
and interesting wide-ranging interview
okay so that's tomorrow on the program
now as a result of that all of our sort
of regular news stories tomorrow are
going to get pushed to the bonus show
tomorrow and I'm going to talk about a
couple of these things today too to sort
of preview what it is that we're going
to be talking about there is a there is
a breaking story that Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson is already considering
resignation from the Donald J Trump
administration and it has everything to
do reportedly there's an article in the
hill about this it has everything to do
with the recent comments from Donald
Trump criticizing Attorney General Jeff
Sessions saying I don't know white
sessions recused himself on Trump Russia
if I had known he was going to recuse
himself on Trump Russia I wouldn't have
hired him in the first place and this
revelation from Rex Tillerson is
absolutely stunning because look at what
you have had so far in the first six
months of the Trump administration
you've seen the forced resignation in
shame of National Security Advisor
Michael Flynn for connections to and
lies about Russia and other foreign
agency foreign foreign countries and
endless scandal you've seen the
resignation of the White House press
secretary Sean Spicer supposedly because
of the hiring of Anthony scaramouche II
as director of White House
communications although it is very hard
for me to believe that that's the real
reason maybe the straw that broke the
camel's back but come on I mean that
that's that's what got him to quit seems
he wanted an out you are now talking
about potentially Donald Trump trying to
push Jeff Sessions towards resignation
which would potentially allow Donald
Trump to install someone there as
Attorney General at the Justice
Department who would not be recused on
issues related to Russia which seems
increasingly important for Trump as we
have now learned that special prosecutor
Robert Muller is investigating Donald
Trump's personal business dealings and
finances as part of his investigation
into Trump Russia so you've got
resignation of Flynn resignation of Sean
Spicer possible upcoming resignation of
Jeff Sessions now you've got the
Secretary of State the top diplomat of
the United States president around the
world saying he's thinking of
resignation as well and you've already
had James Comey fired
you've got possibly this this
possibility of looking to fire robert
muller you've had donald trump already
talking about pardoning himself or
family members or aides with his lawyers
his personal lawyer mark causa wits has
stepped away from leading the legal team
when it comes to trump Russia apparently
still an attorney but it's sort of a
complex thing
there is no way at this point that it
can even be remotely justified that
there's nothing to see here and this is
a normal administration and there is no
scandal and if indeed Rex Tillerson were
to resign
what's next right I mean is it Alex
Jones
Secretary of State who is going to
investigate fluoride turning frogs gay
or whatever the case may be and and to
be perfectly honest with you when I read
about Spicer's resigning because
scaramouche she is White House coms
director or Rex Tillerson might resign
because Trump criticizing Jeff Sessions
is unprofessional it's really hard to
believe that these are the only reasons
right it sort of seems like it's
possible that these are being taken as
opportunities to get the hell out of
Dodge but you know now all of a sudden
Tillerson thinks Trump is unprofessional
because he criticized Jeff Sessions in a
New York Times interview look at
everything that that that has been
happening for the last six months and it
is it is absolutely stunning that this
is what we're dealing with and before we
dig into this further if this is your
first live stream that you're watching
participating in these are live streams
that are live in the sense that I'm
talking to you right now and you can
participate if you want which relates to
item number two on our list which is
that super chat is on super chat is the
dollar sign at the bottom of the chat
window if you would like to ask a
question and have me respond if you have
a comment that you want me to read and
then potentially respond to you can use
the dollar sign at the bottom of the
chat window it is called super chat
press the dollar sign that's it
sometimes people unsure what to do with
the dollar sign you just click it tap it
and you will be able to super chat
number three any new members or patrons
during the livestream will get live
shout outs and thank-yous from me david
pakman.com slash membership for
membership patreon.com slash david
pakman show for patreon by the way we
started this live stream just for
patrons short of our short-term target
of 1,800 patrons let's just get to 1800
right let's do it if we get to 1,800
patrons I will create and announce a
live stream only 50% discount code for
membership we're only for patrons away
$1.00 from four different people will
get us to eight
hundred patrons and believe me folks
believe me I will create and announce a
40% discount code if we can make that
happen
and lastly obvious trolling and hate
will get you banned it is stunning we
are only six minutes and 45 seconds
roughly into this stream and multiple
people have already been blocked
multiple people have been blocked and in
fact I'm blocking someone right now
buh-bye block button is free the
moderators have been fully deputized to
use their judgment in conjunction with
the direction I've given in terms of
blocking and banning people it's just
just don't do it
just don't do it it doesn't make any
sense okay so I will get two super chats
shortly and we will do thank yous and
all of that stuff upcoming another major
bit of news we did a story on the
regular show today and I don't know if
we have already published this clip or
if it if it's going live shortly so Sean
Spicer resigned over the weekend because
director of Anthony scaramouche II was
hired as director of communications for
the White House this guy's a total joke
scaramouche a long history of
criticizing Trump then started
feverishly deleting anti-trump tweets
from his Twitter account in order to
scrub his internet history he shows up
on CNN with Jake Tapper and he says hey
I have a source I've got an anonymous
source that told me it might not have
been Russia that hacked us because if
Russia did it we would never know
because Russia's good enough not to put
their finger prints on hacking and Jake
Tapper pressed Anthony scaramouche II
and said well hold on a second an
anonymous source I mean who is that who
is that that's that's that's telling you
this must be some expert in
cybersecurity and Anthony scaramouche II
admitted it was Donald Trump Donald
Trump who was amazed at how much his 10
year old kid Barron knew about computers
said if Russia did this we would know
interesting it has now leaked that
Vladimir Putin
told that to Donald Trump think about
the flow the path that this information
has taken we hear on national news from
the director of communications from the
White House that a source told him
Russia did it they're good enough that
we wouldn't know pressed he admits it
was actually president Trump who told me
that well we know President Trump is
clueless when it comes to technology and
cyber security but still who planted
that idea in his head it turns out
according to a new report from The New
York Times that it was Vladimir Putin
himself who told Donald Trump listen if
we had done it our fingerprints wouldn't
be on it thus it's fake you are meant to
be tricked into thinking that we did the
hacking because if we really did the
hacking you wouldn't actually know it
put aside all the other stuff about
Trump Russia right what we have de facto
is a White House that goes on national
news and makes arguments sites talking
points that they got from the Russian
leader whatever you want to say about
will find out about this collusion or we
won't find out about that collusion or
exes fake news or why is fake news
whatever the case may be we have a
president who got a talking point from
Vladimir Putin and then gave it to the
director of White House communications
who then went on national corporate
media and tried to defend the
indefensible which is that for whatever
reason they still aren't sure that what
all of our intelligence agencies believe
happened is what happened
the Russian president is directly
transmitting talking points through
corporate media interviews that's what
we've got and that that's why the at
this point and I said this on the
program today if you had total innocence
from the Trump team on everything
related to Russia these people are
idiots why would you constantly lie why
would you constantly parrot Russian
talking points why would you do
everything since being inaugurated that
Donald that Vladimir Putin would want
you to do if you're completely innocent
why would you be talking about pardoning
yourself and your kids and associates if
you're completely innocent if these
people are innocent they are the dumbest
innocent people that I have ever heard
of or seen or read about period and that
is increasingly the sort of
unexplainable the the unintelligible we
have no realistic thought as to why
so-called innocent people are lying and
acting in what could not possibly be a
more Sevilla slee suspicious way and the
Rex Tillerson resignation if it happens
believe me folks it is going to be
stunning absolutely stunning we're six
months in we're six months in at this
point okay all right let's get to some
Super chats here we've got a $5 Super
chat from repentant gamer will you
challenge Dave Rubin on his economic
views based on what I've heard from him
he doesn't seem to know much you have
better economic knowledge by far I plan
to talk with Dave Rubin about the idea
of how classical liberalism is an
ideology that is being sort of it's a
box that increasingly people are
checking and I think many of those
people don't have any clue what
classical liberalism is I think many
people have no idea how conservative
classical liberalism is and in in
talking about that I am absolutely going
to be referencing what a classical
liberal would believe about free markets
about trade about healthcare right so I
think that economics is absolutely going
to be part of my interview with Dave
Rubin which gets me to my next super
chat a $2 super chat from double X
Jamaica who said when are you going to
talk to Dave Rubin so if you miss the
very top of the livestream tomorrow okay
Tuesday July 25th as of right now the
plan is the entire broadcast show on our
200 radio and television stations and on
DirecTV and Dish Network will be a a one
on one an in-depth one on one with Dave
Rubin host of the Rubin report there's a
lot to talk about in and over 350
questions have been submitted by you
through the reddit discussion forum
thread about this through social media
through a number of different venues so
that's the plan we're gonna do an entire
hour with Dave Rubin and then the normal
stories will be on tomorrow's bonus show
so yet additional incentive not only is
the bonus show absolutely tremendous but
tomorrow the bonus show will be where
the regular stories arm you can sign up
at david pakman.com slash membership and
on that note let me say a few thank-yous
we are so the context before I even do
the thank-yous the context is we're
getting crushed on YouTube ok long story
short I wish I had some other way to
explain this to you but but I don't we
are getting destroyed on YouTube we've
lost 85 percent of our YouTube ad
revenue okay and this started after a
really strong start around the the
number of the red number 1 on this image
at the beginning of the year we
initially lost 99% of our YouTube
revenue when what's known as the YouTube
advertiser boycott started now I don't
even want to rehash everything that that
is because many of you have heard it but
if you want to learn more about it and
how it's crushing us there's a New York
Times article about the David Pakman
show how YouTube's shifting algorithms
hurt independent media there's also
another article in Wired want a better
web here's an idea
pay for it these are two articles that
you can find at david pakman.com slash
press that will catch you up on the
youtube ad boycott but the trajectory
has been we lost 99% of YouTube ad
revenue it looked like things were
starting to improve as you see trending
up from number 2 to 3 into sort of early
May late May and then just falling off a
cliff again at the end of June and we've
had about another month of what I would
call full crisis mode and this appears
to be the new normal okay I mean I wish
I could tell you that this was going to
get better there is no in the
at this point that we are going to ever
earn anything more than roughly 15% of
what we used to be earning on our
YouTube channel this is why and I want
to keep doing long-form interviews
long-form deep dives we've got a
miniseries planned on critical thinking
I want to be doing all of this stuff I
don't want this to affect us which is
why we are really talking about
membership and financial contributions
and making up the lost revenue so if you
want a membership you get the bonus show
you get the commercial-free all-access
pass you can go to david pakman.com
slash membership 6 bucks a month 60
bucks a year this is mostly how we're
funded okay I mean it's this it's
through our audience if you want to
discount off of membership you can use
the coupon code
I voted 17 and on that note I want to
send a huge thank you to Denise Barnett
who has just signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership Denise thank
you so much I really appreciate it also
signing up just what we've been chatting
here are Justin Pryor Justin Pryor has
signed up as well as Matthew Martinez
and Beverly Smith all of whom have
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership thank you I mean genuinely
thank you you're helping to solve the
YouTube ad problem and in addition to
that we have a patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin show you can just
throw in a dollar a month and what I can
tell you is two things number one we are
for patrons away from hitting 1,800 help
me get to 1,800 okay which is our next
pit stop on the way to 2,000 if you can
get us to 1,800 patrons and it doesn't
matter how much you contribute by the
end of this live stream which really
folks we should be able to do I will
create a secret member
ship discount code a 50% off code and I
will tell you what that code is here on
the stream and not anywhere else okay
and then you will be able to sign up for
membership at half price that's if we
can get to just 1,800 1,800 patrons and
I know it's you know it's a pain when we
talk about this stuff it's a pain when
we well if we had to adjust our program
because of the funding crisis I can
assure you that would be more of a pain
so help us make that up and and we'll
continue to produce all the great stuff
that we want to keep producing Ilya
Levin has sent a five-dollar super chat
asking why he's taking out of why is
taking money out of politics become a
mostly progressive issue shouldn't this
be an agenda that other political
ideologies can support well yes and no I
mean if you if you're right what would
be called a full libertarian you would
see taking money out of politics as not
the free-market the total libertarian
perspective would be take don't get
involved in any way in how politics can
be funded if people have money they want
to contribute let them contribute the
money if companies have money they want
to contribute let them contribute the
money and so it actually is not really
if if you have any sense of ethics
fairness and justice then you would
understand the importance of taking
money out of politics if you want to
stop the rampant corruption not all of
it but part of it that is inherent in
our political system then you would be
behind taking money out of politics but
if your priority is I don't want any
regulation period of anything financial
whatever governmental then no you
wouldn't care about taking money out of
politics because you would say hey
people who are able to donate should be
allowed to donate whatever it is that
they want so I think it's sad that it is
overwhelmingly a progressive issue and
by the way oh yeah it's on many issues
we I've talked about this there are so
many issues where Democrats and
Republicans are very very different
unfortunately money out of politics is
overwhelmingly a progressive issue but
it is not some
that corporate Democrats or Democrats
Inc as I like to say are taking a huge
interest in and really any establishment
politician that was put into power by
the system that we currently have why
would they want to change that system
they're empowered because of that system
why would they say hey let's change
let's break the system that got us here
so that soon will be gone it doesn't
really make any sense right so I think
that there it's true that it is a
progressive issue but it is not an issue
that Democrats are completely united
behind and that's sad incredibly sad and
very low-energy Ryan Alexander has sent
a $5 Super chat saying what's the status
on the progressive action coordinator
idea from the January fundraiser are you
still considering it and what would that
look like yeah so listen we we did a
fundraiser in January and we were short
of our total fundraising goal so we've
been able to do some of the things so
far that we were raising money for
including significant studio
improvements and a number of other
changes my initial idea was okay we fell
short of the fund raise of the total
fundraising goal maybe we can combine a
new marketing position with the
progressive engagement coordinator as I
was calling it and go about it that way
and make it one position rather than two
separate positions then when we were
very close to making that higher then
the YouTube advertiser boycott hit and
then the focus was hiring new people
hold on a second we've got to make up
the money that we just lost initially
ninety-nine percent loss and and
ultimately now we are down about
eighty-five percent so it's just on hold
right I mean if we had if some
combination of if we had hit the full
fundraising goal back in January or if
we had not experienced the YouTube ad
pocalypse advertiser boycott then we
probably would have done that for now
but now but before we can look at
additional hiring we need to make up the
lost YouTube revenue we've got to get
you know the financial situation in
order but still something that I think
is hugely important Ryan
I've by no means forgotten about it it's
just had to be postponed for for the
reasons I mentioned chunky lover 5:39
has sent a to Australian dollar super
chat saying just got here what if I
missed well we a now I I mentioned that
tomorrow we will be talking to Dave
Rubin for the full hour on the broadcast
program we will be talking about a lot
of different things we were going to be
talking about classical liberalism we
are going to be talking about his
politics we will be talking about the
Rubin report we will be talking about
Dave's interview style we will be
talking about Donald Trump and so many
other things and viewers have already
submitted 350 questions for that
interview we will not get the 350
questions but we will get to some of
them I have also told you that the
latest news is that we now have
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
considering resigning as a result of the
unprofessionalism unprofessionalism that
he is attributed to Trump's criticism of
Jeff Sessions in a recent New York Times
interview and in addition to that we've
learned that Anthony scaramouche's
claimed that came from Donald Trump that
if Russia hacked we wouldn't know it
because they're so good at it that
actually came from Vladimir Putin so we
now have Trump Associates publicly on
corporate media parroting talking points
that originated with Russian President
Vladimir Putin we did some Super chats I
talked about the YouTube ad pocalypse
situation that's basically it chunky
lover okay so I think that that more or
less gets us caught up on in terms of
what we've been talking about so far and
on that note let me do a couple more
thank-yous we are in the middle of a
major David Pakman show membership drive
we have a coupon code
I voted 17 and we have a brand new
member William McDonald William thank
you thank you so much for being a david
pakman show member William has signed up
on our website he has entered the coupon
code
I voted 17
and as a result he has saved 40% off of
membership which is a pretty big deal
you get a hundred percent of the
benefits but you don't pay full price
which is a beautiful thing for a lot of
people also signing up just now on our
website is Maxwell Hetzel max Hetzel
thank you so much for signing up
Julian Hunt is a new david pakman show
member and david tapper david tapper
unclear if there's any relationship to
Jake Tapper but indeed we have a new
member with that last name and for that
I think we can all be very very glad I
think for every member we can all be
glad and oh and Amy Carney Amy Carney
signing up as well as I was about to
move off of that topic I will remind you
if you're interested in a 50% discount
off of membership if we get to 1,800
patrons at patreon.com slash david
pakman show that's only four more okay
if four people contribute as little as a
dollar a month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show I will create and
release a 50% discount code for
membership and patreon is the most
direct and simple path to making up for
that lost ad revenue that we've had for
people and we will release a 50%
discount code let's go back to some more
Super chats Jacob Young has sent a $5
super chat how do you think media should
go about differentiating the difference
between real news and propaganda well
I'm not sure I totally understand the
question how should media differentiate
between real news and propaganda
I guess you're talking about media
reports about other news let me answer
it a little more generally since I'm not
exactly sure what what the exact
question is I think that many corporate
media outlets have deliberately blurred
the lines between news and opinion
journalism so that many people are
watching opinion
journalism and believe that it is news
reporting of some kind and assume that
things have sort of been fact-checked in
the same way that you know a New York
Times report on on a particular event
has been fact checked and that is it's
deliberate and Fox News has become very
very good at that Infowars has become
very good at that I make clear with our
program we're doing an opinion show
which is my opinion and analysis and
it's based on reports that have come
from elsewhere so what I do is we have a
number of media outlets that we no
longer use as sources because I find
that they are either propagandistic or
just simply unreliable so we have
reduced the list of sources
maybe not reduced but I guess we've sort
of fine-tuned we've refined the list of
sources that we use as source articles
we no longer use these article farms
that are basically taking like a New
York Times article and rewriting it we
no longer source to the extent that that
were able any of those new sites and I
think this this sort of has to happen at
the individual media outlet level okay
Jacob Chris call Chris call has sent a
$2 super chat saying Pakman show has
always been the [ __ ] hi to Lois all
right well I'm sure Lois appreciates
that I saw Lois over the weekend at a
wedding and he was he was doing great he
was doing great he actually gave a
speech at the wedding and it was quite
good and he he communicated to me at the
end of the wedding that his experience
on the David Pakman show was
instrumental in him being comfortable
giving that speech and he prepared a
pretty pretty good speech I must say
boxy Brown has sent the five dollar
super chat what's up with the snare drum
and practice pad behind you do you play
the drums also have you ever watched
Aqua Teen Hunger Force do you like it I
do play the drums because I live in an
apartment
I can't really have like a full acoustic
drum set here so I have a snare drum
small snare drum I think that's only a 5
inch deep snare drum and I put actually
it's three practice pads on top of it so
with the three pack practice pads I can
keep the snares on and it still has a
little bit of that snare feel and sound
but it is very quiet so yeah I play
drums I played in a band when I lived in
Brooklyn etc etc I have seen probably 30
seconds of Aqua Teen Hunger Force in my
life I don't remember if I liked it I
don't remember if I liked it but it was
uh it was it was um it was okay I mean I
don't know that the animation was cool I
like the look of it but I did not die
just got into it I'm into a few cartoons
I like Archer Bob's Burgers isn't bad
and of course friend of the show Sam
cedar is a couple of voices now in Bob's
Burgers I've been a big family guy fan
for awhile Simpsons fan for a long time
yeah okay Lyle frappe EA has sent a to
Canadian dollar super chat scaramouche's
integrity lasted one day lol hashtag hey
Pat yeah scaramouche II I mean it lasted
hours it lasted just a few hours I would
say at this point and immediately I mean
just laughable completely and totally
laughable completely unqualified and I
actually think scaramouche II could do
quite a bit of damage because he's
erratic he'd the guy is a livewire and
he seems completely out of control he'll
say almost anything at any time and I
think that I'm hoping that he will do
some serious damage to the Trump
administration which of course the
headline for it for this live stream
that Secretary of State Rex Tillerson is
thinking of resigning that could do some
pretty damn big damage to the Trump
administration as well
xx Jamaica sent a $2 super chat saying
you should talk to you should talk some
sense into sargon of akkad yeah I mean I
don't know I don't
know exactly what you have in mind I
don't know that Sargon is particularly
interested in appearing on the show
anytime soon if he were I would probably
want to do it like as a YouTube only
thing because my YouTube audience is
very keyed in to whoo Sargon of Akkad is
my radio audience probably not I would
be shocked if my radio and television
and DirecTV audience has any idea who
Sargon is so sorry I would be glad to
talk to Sargon both live depending on
what the topic is you know I would
obviously want to figure out what we
would talk about would be glad to do it
I don't know that he's super interested
in that he's big-time now I don't think
he needs the likes of the david pakman
show anymore
Garrett North has sent a to $10 super
chat David I just became a patreon hope
this helps - Thank You Garrett and it is
a patron you are a patreon patron yeah
thank you very much and I guess I might
as well at this point get to the
thank-yous just so I can get caught up
we are trying to get to 1,800 patreon
patrons by the end of the stream we are
now at 1798 so we have closed the gap by
50% we are trying to get to 1,800 paid
patrons by the end of the day as as well
I don't know what which name was used by
the super chatter Garrett North but what
I'm seeing is that Terry lemon has just
pledged two dollars a month on
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
jeremy levy has pledged two dollars a
month at patreon.com slash david pakman
show please please please help us get
there we are looking for 1,800 patrons
by the end of the live stream and if we
do that and I am optimistic we're gonna
do it if we get to 1,800 patrons by the
end of the live stream I will create and
release only to you a 50% and you know
what let's go really crazy I will create
and release to you a 55%
membership discount code which will be
good only until midnight tonight I won't
tell any of my other viewers about it it
will just be here on the live stream and
you will then be able to get a
membership at a fifty five percent
discount which I think trust me folks
you folks will really like it I think
you will absolutely really really like
it so again if you have if you still
want to get your questions in and you
miss this tomorrow on the broadcast show
we're gonna have dave rubin for the full
hour okay dave rubin host of rubin
report will be my full show guests
tomorrow all topics will be on the table
his classical liberalism
the rubin report his interviewing
technique of not being particularly
argumentative which not everybody likes
i don't know everything is on the table
if you still have questions there's a
reddit discussion thread which is
currently stick eed at the top of david
pakman.com slash read it you will note
that it has at this point two hundred
and thirty five comments and growing
almost by the minute and if you have any
questions i am keeping an eye on that
thread so so rest assured that it will
be reviewed you can put in your question
for dave rubin there and i think it's
gonna be fantastic i think it's gonna be
a opening experience
I know that you know that my interview
style it's not the same as Dave Reubens
and I think that we will hopefully what
I want to do is get clarity on what are
Dave's politics right now like when he
says he's a classical liberal what does
that mean is classical liberalism more
progressive or more conservative I think
you know my feelings about that so so
that's that's gonna be absolutely
tremendous and also I want to tell you
as far as what's upcoming on the program
because we've got just absolutely
tremendous stuff up coming on the show
we have david pakman show summer
vacation coming up okay and don't worry
we're still two three weeks away from it
but we are working on some awesome stuff
awesome stuff for you
as for that vacation because we're gonna
keep releasing new content you know how
now it's popular for people on the right
to say oh the left is so violent so vie
everybody on the left is so violent
they're hurting people and it's really
the left that turns to violence to try
to solve political problems we've got a
tremendous piece on the myth of the
violent left and the truly violent right
it is incredibly well sourced it is
incredibly well edited and we had our
intern Brian work on this we have
producer Noah Ferguson working on it
Pat's involved in everything that we do
on the show so it's been a team effort
to get that done we have in production
right now a long-form piece on classical
liberalism I think you are going to love
this piece particularly it's going to
come out in the wake of tomorrow's Dave
Rubin interview and that one is about 75
80 percent done we are in the editing
phase right now we have a completely
just an amazingly well researched piece
on voter fraud and voter suppression the
right says in-person voter fraud is a
major problem the facts say it's not but
we know that it's being used as a
pretext by the right to continue we've
also got oh no it looks like I it looks
like I got disconnected there for a
second did anybody see that I got a
message that we were that the stream
went dead for a second but I think we're
back we still here can people see me
it's showing live on my end hmm screams
back up okay good
screams back up I'll continue so anyway
we've got the voter suppression peace a
talking point from some is socialism has
never worked people who say that
understand very little now I am NOT a
socialist I am a social democrat I sort
of favor social democracy however if
we're really going to have a
conversation about economic
models we should understand what those
models are in other words the difference
between socialism and communism for
example and really understand if these
catchphrases oh it's never worked are
those true and we've got a piece coming
up on that and then lastly we've got an
upcoming investigation into race and IQ
which is a subject that's been sort of
forced into the into the limelight
lately and we also have a awesome
critical thinking miniseries that is
about 75% of the way done in terms of
the scripting and then we still have to
do the production on it so a lot of this
stuff is funded directly you know by
members and patrons and it's really
really good stuff and I'm glad that
we're able to do more of it and this was
one of the goals of our January
fundraiser that January fundraiser was
short of its goal but at the same time
we were still able to do more things as
a result of that so that's all really
really good okay super chats Lyle frappe
ei sent to five Canadian dollar super
chat realistically how would it go down
if Trump was to be removed from office
we wake up one day and he's gone is
there a process besides impeachment well
impeachment would be one process
resignation would be another yeah I mean
on a particular day Trump would be gone
and it would be it would be fascinating
and you know what I don't know that it's
actually the best thing and I've talked
about why before so I won't rehash that
but being scandal-ridden for the next
three and a half years might actually be
the best thing in terms of preventing
any kind of whack at whacked-out
right-wing agenda floppy kid sent the
five Canadian dollar super chat saying
any thoughts on the recent troubling
developments with Jill Stein too soon to
judge yeah I'm waiting
I've actually so I and I've been talking
with our production team about you know
at some point we might have to cover
Jill Stein in Russia because Jill Stein
appears to also have some troubling
connections to Russia and we've not
talked about it because it was a very
speculative case but that case is
becoming stronger and stronger on a
regular basis and at some point floppy
we may have to dig into Jill Stein and
Russia Google that if you're not sure
what's going on but it's pretty pretty
interesting stuff Brian Poitras has sent
a ten-dollar super chat with no
- no comment chunky lover 5:39 has sent
a to Australian dollar super chat saying
route just became a patron thank you I
will check in on patreon very soon brian
port Poitras coming back again with a
ten dollar super chat chris wallace
confronts and crushes anthony
scaramouche Ian Trump's hypocrisy in
this video anthony scaramouche she calls
Trump one of the most effective
communicators of all time what is your
take my take is Donald Trump has been an
effective communicator to a very
particular group of people and it has
worked enough to get him into the White
House and for that Hey all power to him
what happens next may not be something
he can talk his way out of we will see
we've got a $2 super chat from game fire
74 ideas to identify and encourage non
voters to vote okay here's one technique
that I found is really effective for
encouraging people who don't care about
voting to vote often the conversation
will go like this oh you don't vote why
not well politicians don't care about
what I think my vote doesn't change
anything
that's interesting what what do you care
about well I care about the environment
well that's interesting what do our
elected officials think about the
environment mmm I don't really know I
mean I guess maybe some of them care
about it and so I'm gonna don't oh
that's interesting
what what do you think would would
happen if every single one of our
elected officials did care about the
environment I don't know I guess I never
really thought about it really do you
think if we had a hundred percent of our
elected officials taking climate change
seriously instead of just whatever
percentage it but percent it is forty
five percent I don't know do you think
that that might make a difference if we
doubled the number of people who are
representing us who care about the
environment I guess that might might
make a difference oh that's interesting
so do you think maybe it actually does
matter who we have in there yeah I guess
I never really thought about it that way
you can apply that conversation to just
about any issue and that that's just one
exam
right game fire but there are all there
are many other similar types of
conversations you can have and we'll
probably talk about that a little bit
more jake w22 cent to $5 super chat all
else equal who do you think would be
more dangerous as president Trump or
Mike Pence okay I get heat every time I
address this because I've said many
times pence would not be a
scandal-ridden and he would start
getting stuff done because he would
unify Republicans and things would start
to happen in almost every way Donald
Trump is less dangerous than pence in
that many of his ideas are just never
gonna happen and the constant scandal
prevents him from getting anything done
there is one area where I believe Donald
Trump is way more dangerous than Mike
Pence Mike Pence would crush him when he
when it comes to actually getting
getting stuff done but as Donald Trump's
approval rating continues to trickle
down as he feels the pressure of robert
muller continuing to investigate more
and more deeply what it is that he is
doing and has done he might erratically
do something completely irreversible and
and in terms of military action against
the country and I believe that on that
front Mike Pence would be way more
restrained and that that's my sense I
don't know where that puts me in the net
Frank macwrite has sent the $20 super
jet please let Pat know rabbits are not
rodents yeah this is related to today's
bonus show which Frank gets access to
because he is a david pakman show member
and you could know what what he's
talking about
anyway I I was I didn't think rabbits
were rodents Pat insisted that they were
and since I didn't know I let him know I
I said okay well that must be the case I
will let him know Frank that rabbits are
not rodents and if you're curious what
that conversation is about I will say no
more you will have to sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership and become a
member and on that note I do have very
very exciting news which is that on
number of people I would say any number
of people have continued to sign up for
membership while we've been talking here
I just want to say thank you to them
just to ensure that nobody's support
goes unthanked Rex Fowler Thank You Rex
you have signed up and started to chip
away at the YouTube ad apocalypses
damaging effects Jonathan Nieves has
signed up Charles up site this is
there's two names here Charles Williams
okay interesting signed up one thing
says Charles O Connor but then the other
thing says Charles Williams in any case
let's go with Charles Williams Charl
Charles Williams has signed up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership and if you want the discount
code you just type in I voted 17 and I
have major breaking news with regard to
my patreon challenge okay we have
surpassed the 1,800 patron mark and I
promised that if we got to 1,800 patrons
by the end of the livestream I would
create and release just for you a coupon
code that will save you fifty five
percent off of membership well
Melinda Mitchell has pledged $1 a month
on patreon Lane winter has pledged $1 a
month on patreon
Mauricio Gonzales who also goes by
chunky levar 5:39 has pledged $2 a month
on patreon
Shane winter has pledged $2 a month on
patreon and just to be nice Joel Jamaica
has increased their pledge from $2 a
month
to $5 a month on patreon so on that note
I am going to create a coupon code right
now which will give you a fifty five
percent discount off of membership this
is a big league discount what would be a
funny code to create here maybe
something related to recent news not
sure what would be a funny coupon code
we've had some pretty funny ones
what about what about something Cobb
feffy related yeah let's just do
something Cobb feffy keep it simple I am
creating a coupon code this coupon code
will be incredibly useful to you I am
going to type it into the chat and I am
putting in fifty five percent discount
code it is Cobb feffy fifty five cop
fifty fifty five all one word all
lowercase no spaces CoV f e fe
fifty-five that gives you a 50% discount
off of your membership this coupon will
expire and it will expire at midnight
tonight so you have about just under
just over five hours the coupon code is
cob feffy 55 and by all means have added
folks victor Savelle has sent a $10
super chat hi David how are you planning
to continue your efforts on supporting
net neutrality do you have any news on
the current standing on the possible
outcome of the FCC bill great work as
always we have been and will continue to
talk about net neutrality because it is
an issue of to call it paramount
importance would sort of be an
understatement and like campaign finance
reform net neutrality is I mean they
don't have to get into it most of you
probably understand already just hugely
hugely important and we're gonna keep
talking about it and we will keep
calling my elected officials and we'll
do everything we can victor our rich ro
path a corp a fac has sent a 2 dollar
super chat asking what are your favorite
restaurants in Waltham Massachusetts
well sadly retro I I went to graduate
school in Waltham Massachusetts at the
great school Bentley University and I
could not tell you a single wall fan
restaurant that I like because I know
very few of them and I've not
to any particularly good one so rather
than then disparage any restaurants or
name restaurants that I don't really
think are good because I take restaurant
recommendations incredibly seriously I
will remain silent on that issue Thank
You Gina Chase has sent a five dollar
super chat no question or comment thank
you very much Frank macwrite has sent
the twenty dollar super chat saying for
your information I almost missed the
live broadcast because YouTube did not
notify me normally I get a notification
on the bell icon in the top right an
email and an iPhone notification I got
lucky today
that's weird Frank because I'm signed up
to those same same notifications and
yeah I got them I just looked at my
email and I receive them so it must have
been some kind of a some kind of an
error or something I don't know but yeah
I don't know what to tell you Frank but
yes please be notified about all of our
live streams and new videos you can use
the Bell button on our YouTube channel
and you can select to be notified when
we go live when new videos are uploaded
etcetera etc and yeah that's absolutely
major and wow people are really taking
advantage of the coupon code that we
just released at the beginning of the
livestream is a challenge and that
challenge was if we can get to 1,800
patrons at patreon.com slash david
pakman show my promise to the audience
was I would create and release a fifty
five percent discount coupon code that
coupon code has been released
it is cob fifty fifty five cob feffy
fifty five and as a result we've already
got Carl Collins who has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership using
the code we've got Joshua Coleman who
has signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership using the coupon code to give
you a sense of what fifty five percent
off is if you select the $6 a month
membership and use the coupon code cop
fifty fifty five which will be good
until midnight tonight midnight Pacific
I believe it is
that makes your monthly membership 2
dollars and 70 cents for two dollars and
70 cents you will get the bonus show as
well as the commercial free audio and
video streams of the show if you decide
to go with the yearly 55 percent
discount membership you switch over to
the $60 a year membership you type in
cop 50 55 and that gives you a fifty
five percent discount you're talking
about twenty seven dollars a year that's
two dollars and 25 cents per month and
that is good until midnight so folks
people are telling me this is the best
coupon code and you know who doesn't
love cop feffy and victoria pollock has
also just signed up using that coupon
code and the super chats continue to
roll in let's get to some of those Frank
macwrite sending another $20 superjet
Frank is the known David Pakman show
super chat all-star he's known to
authorities as far as I'm sorry I am
aware of I it also reintroduced super
chat to me as if I have never done them
and we all know that I have ahh so there
might be some broader thing going on
with your account Frank where somehow
your preferences may have been cleared
yeah that's weird
Gina chase following up with a $2.00
super chat no question or comment thank
you very much and then we have Victor
Savelle also a super chat all-star $10
super Chad just wanted to mention how
much I admire your work I will have a
segment on my nightly stream tonight
about your excellent work not much but
the best I can do thanks Victor I really
appreciate that and all recommendations
to support independent media are
valuable recommendations and and really
appreciated recommendations and I can't
I can't thank you enough I mean
genuinely anything that anybody can do
to support our work is appreciated and
on that note the new members are just
flying in we've got Russell stone who
has signed up using the exclusive July
24th cob feffy discount code which is
cob feffy 55 getting a $2 and 70 cent a
month membership nice nice Russell Peter
Kowalski signed up using the coupon code
and so has cast
Janson thanks to all of you very very
much appreciated and on that note we are
going to call it because I've got to go
prepare for my full hour with Dave Rubin
tomorrow I want to be fully prepared and
I want to review everybody's comments
questions suggestions etc so use the
coupon code
keep it going it's good until midnight
and then it's gone gone into the ethier
ether sorry
like the ephemera of Sean Spicer which
now are also gone thanks for joining me
big interview tomorrow with Dave Rubin